this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so today I'll be reporting on the
most recent findings in the search for
the evolution of the origin of the genes
40 toxin production in Coke Tablas
heterotroph astray Steve as Gillian
mentioned t toxin is a secondary
metabolite and virulence determinant
that was the cause of the southern corn
leaf blight epidemic in 1970 I'll be
presenting phylogenetic and statistical
analysis that showed that the genes
involved in T toxin production share a
common evolutionary origin with
ornithologist gene clusters and several
other species of fungi and that they may
be foreign to the Coco Alba cetera
Stouffer's genome i'll also be
presenting functional analyses of two
genes that are found in these other
ornithologist clusters that are not
found in coca is heterotroph --is as
Scalia mentioned this work informs our
understanding of how hyper virulent
strains of fungi evolve which could help
us to prevent epidemics like the
southern corn leaf blight from the
current future in order to understand
the evolution of hyper virulence in
Colaba satirist ofus race T who first
must understand the conditions that led
to this epidemic as well as the
mechanism underlying the interaction
between the fungus and the plants back
in 1970 the agricultural industry was
ravished by the southern corn leaf
blight epidemic the first evidence of
this occurred in nineteen in March in
Florida and due to the warm and wet
conditions that year spread rapidly up
the east coast and into Canada covering
30 states and costing the corn industry
an estimated 1 billion dollars it was so
severe that it actually made the cover
of The New York Times though doubts a
rare achievement for a plant pathogen
now the underlying conditions of the
weather were not the only cause only
contributed to this epidemic
it was also caused by the emergence of a
new race of a relatively innocuous plant
pathogen co-collaborators drove this
race tea that had in hyper virulence and
specific effects on a variety of corn
plants that were widely grown at that
time those corn plants carried the Texas
male sterile cytoplasm or TCMS now male
sterility confers or facilitates
outcrossing for hybrid vigor and which
eliminates the cost associated with
detasseling at the
of the epidemic more than 80% of corn in
United States that was used for hybrid
production used the t cytoplasm the t
cytoplasm
unbeknownst to growers at that time was
the fact that this t cytoplasm also
confer susceptibility to this newly
emerging race of Picabo center strophes
here's a field of corn carrying t
cytoplasm inoculated with ray so the
relatively innocuous pathogen that was
previously known and was not considered
a threat to agriculture and then race
team and you can see the devastating
effects that inoculation with race t has
so quit researchers quickly determined
that the race t differed from race oh by
the production of a small metabolite
that came to be known as t toxin t toxin
is a linear polychaete side of family of
linear polyketides invariant chain links
with c41 the 41 carbon length backbone
being the most potent here you can see
infiltration of TCMS corn with culture
filtrates from race t on the left and
race though on the right you can see
that massive chlorosis that this has the
effect of this has on the plants t toxin
production segregates one to one in the
crosses with race oh the non toxic
boosting strain which suggested that
this genes underlying production came
from or were driven by a single locus t
toxin accomplishes this hyper virulence
due to this specific interaction with a
protein that is unique to t cytoplasm
corn this protein you are of 13 is found
in the inner mitochondrial membrane of t
CMS or this protein confers the
cytoplasmic males to really do phenotype
but also confer susceptibility to t
toxin when t toxin is present the
protein actually forms spores in the
mitochondrial membrane releasing the
contents resulting in cell death again
another picture of race versus race t
inoculated on to TCMS corn the unique
susceptibility of TCMS corn to t toxin
and the specificity of this interaction
defined t toxin as a host selective
toxin
now this finding that race t produces t
toxin array so does not spawn this
question of how does this newly evolved
race how did this race this newly
evolved race arise
now those questions being what are the
genes underlying T toxin production and
where did they come from
so after decades of research Gillian and
her associates identified nine genes
involved in T toxin production
collectively known as tox one he's
comprised a complex genetic locus as the
genes are not tightly clustered the
genes are composed of two polyketide
synthases a five oxidoreductases
one decarboxylase and a gene of unknown
function now a toxin is a linear
apologies ID so at least one poly Keith
polyketide synthase gene was expected
these other genes are likely involved in
a modification of the resulting molecule
the genes are associated with a
reciprocal translocation and raced T
relative to R a so you can see that
depicted here in the lower right there
and contrary to the one-to-one
segregation findings the genes are
actually on two separate low-side
referred to as tox 1a and tox 1b they
are inherited together due to the
complex genetics underlying this
reciprocal translocation the genes are
surrounded by highly repeated hg rich
DNA and they're not found in race over
any other close relative here's a
graphical representation of the genes
that I'll be using for the rest of the
talk the colored arrows indicate the
different genes and their orientation
relative to one another
on this background of blue which is the
contig from the recently assembled
genome
notice that the contexts are not
connected and this is reflective of the
fragmented nature of the locus and our
inability to sequence intervening
regions in between them so while it
appeared that the genes for T toxin
production have been identified the
questions to remain where did these
genes come from were they vertically
inherited in Colaba ceteris trophies
race T or where they horizontally
transmitted sometime before the epidemic
a seminal discovery was found by one of
Julian's colleagues Candace Eliot and
which she identified orthologs of the
genes and a different plant pathogen let
the sphere immaculate strikingly the
genes are found in a compact cleaning
array which is not how they're found in
cocoa Alice Harris drove this race team
this prompted a review of available
genome databases including microcosm and
GenBank to search for other putative
ornithologist genes and other species
this resulted in the identification of
several species of fungi but not many
that carry the ornithologist clusters or
parent genes are thoughtless to the
stalks one cluster strikingly again all
these genes are found in a compact
linear array you'll notice that most of
these we are don't video my seats
however there are a few euros show my
seats which is interesting because the
Euro show my C's and the video my C's to
Virge some 350 million years ago also
what you'll notice is that the these
additional clusters carry two additional
genes an ABC binding cassette
transporter and an oxidoreductase not
found in the race tea genome the linear
organization and the additional two
genes found in many of these other
species led us to hypothesize that this
organization and composition was the
ancestral states of the genes found in
Cochabamba centers trophies raised to
you so my research in Gilliam's lab has
been underlined two overarching
questions first what can we learn about
the evolution of stalks one from the
scattered genomic data and two was the
loss of the ABC and ox our genes somehow
critical in the evolution of T toxin
production so I'll break the rest of the
talk we've broken up into sections or
I'll address each of these questions so
what can we learn about the red talks
one evolutionary history for example do
these clusters found other species share
a common evolutionary origin with the
genes for T toxin production and - can
we determine the mode of Harrod
inheritance of stalks one in Colaba
centers trophy sprays t it's not about
answering these questions by using the
coxswain proteins in co-collaborators
trophies to blast the microcosm and
GenBank databases pulling down the top
100 hits from each of these databases
and conducting a phylogenetic analysis
I also evaluated protein features
including amino acid identity and GC
content with the results of these
analysis I was able to infer whether
they had a common evolutionary origin
and whether there was any evidence for
vertical or horizontal transmission
while the identity amino acid identity
and the GC content data were significant
and informative due to the sake of time
I'm going to focus primarily on the
phylogenetic analysis I conducted and
I'll give you the points the main
findings from the amino acid in GC so
firstly individual gene trees
constructed using the tox 1 genes as
query show that the toxin proteins
cluster with high support which supports
a common evolutionary origin of the
genes here I'm just illustrating the PKS
one PKS - gene tree with the top one
proteins blown up so you can see them in
red are the Dafydd iam I seats that
carry these clusters and in green are
the arrocha my disease was interesting
about the topology or the branching
order in these trees is that the Orochi
oh my seats are nested within the
d'Ovidio my seats this is incongruent
with what we would expect given the
taxonomic relationship between of these
classes this also suggests that there
could be a horizontal acquisition by the
remaining seeds from the delta T of my
C's at some point and by congruent what
I'm referring to is phylogenetic
congruence which is an approach to
evaluate the mode of inheritance of
genes by comparing a gene tree to a
species tree which serves as a reference
a species tree like this example can be
constructed using highly conserved
single copy genes of your tax of
interest that's apology here is
reflective of the evolutionary
relationships of your tax in your
dataset so keep an eye on taxa D now if
we construct a gene tree and this gene
tree is congruent with the species tree
taxa D is in the same place then we can
infer that the gene that we're
evaluating has been inherited vertically
much like the genes that are composing
our species tree
now if the gene tree is not congruent
with the species tree as in this example
below then we can infer that there may
be or may have been a horizontal
transmission to that taxa in other words
the gene tree does not conform to is not
congruent with the species tree so what
I was interested in this analysis is the
toxin cluster as a whole in kookaburras
heterotroph is not individual genes so
what I did was instead of conducting
individual gene trees I concatenated all
the genes that talks on locus and and
conducted a phylogenetic analysis to
determine if the genes were congruent to
a species tree like so so here's a
conserved a species tree composed of
conserved genes and all of my talks when
proteins concatenated in a multi locus
sequence typing approach again what I'm
interested in is the topology for the
branching order of the stalks one tree
now this analysis comparison that in
this case is complicated due to the fact
that I don't have an out-group to
include in the data set so the topology
of the Tonquin tree is not directly
comparable to the species stream but
what I can do to evaluate congruence is
to conduct a topological constraints
analysis basically constraining the
stalks one tree to the species tree
topology and seeing if that is
significantly different so here's my
species tree I'm showing us unrooted
format right now so that this because
this emphasizes the divergence between
the sequences here employment want to
point out the euro so my seats in green
and the Delta T of my seats in red and
this long branch the separates the
d'Ovidio my seats from the arrocha my
C's this is in this is indicative of the
divergence between these classes and
what we would expect now if we look at
our stalks one tree I want to also focus
on that same branch between the Orochi
oh my sees and the Dissidia my sees note
that these trees are shown at the same
scale so the divergence between the
arrocha my C's and the DA video my C's
is not what we would expect given their
taxonomic relationships
this is indicates that the genes are
much more similar to the video my C's
than they are
than we would expect them to be also
supporting hypothesis of a horizontal
transmission another couple of points
that I want to make is that in the
species tree cocoa table setter
astrophys is clustered with leprosy your
macula which support which is supported
by other large-scale cosmetic analysis
but in our talks one tree
co-collaborators trophy's is is
clustering with Eddie Miller's a mate is
female and same ATIS is the only other
species of fungi that produces a toxin
with specificity for the RF 13 protein
however we don't think that that is why
their questions are gather in this tree
what we think is happening is a
phenomenon called long branch attraction
in which the two these two clusters are
not together because of their similarity
to one another but because they're
equally dissimilar to the rest of the
taxa in the data set so if we route
these trees into a more conventional
format what we see is the species tree
conforms to larger broader scale
cosmetic analyses rocha my seeds are
sister too and not nested within the dog
videomic seats kögel opposite of
shellfish is the youngest data you got
one of the youngest tax in the data set
buttocks one tree here is midpoint
rooted because again we don't have a
natural out group in the data set well
we can see is the euro so my C's are
clustered or nested within dothe idiom
eyes he said not separate from them and
again hetero stropas is clustering with
DD melanzane tomatoes so here's where i
form to be evaluated the topological
congruence of these two trees by
conducting topological or a phylogenetic
constraints analysis so what what that
does is one in the Bayesian analysis
which is analysis that I'm using the the
tree that's produced has what's called
an estimated model likelihood for that
tree and now you can run separate
analysis running different models and
then you can compare the estimated model
likelihood for each of those trees and
then model the tree with the best
likelihood is your best hypothesis so
what I did was I allowed this analysis
to run unconstrained and I and I
received an estimated model likelihood I
then constrained the data to fit to the
species tree topology and then compared
the model likelihood of a tree to the
unconstraint tree and what I found was
that the coxswain cluster data do not
conform to the species tree in other
words they don't follow a pattern of
strict vertical inheritance estimated
model likelihood a difference was over
1700 and by this metric greater than 150
is considered strong evidence so even
though we can't make a direct comparison
between these trees without a without
being rooted well we can see are some
similarities or dissimilarities between
the trees that give us some information
about mode of inheritance for example in
the species tree see Aquatica sand
Lingam Isis in Goldie Anna's closer
together which is what we would expect
in the talks will entry they do the same
this suggests that the talks one genes
have been inherited vertically through
evolutionary time in those lineages also
we can see is a spicata a bi and was
messed up a quiz koalas clustered
together in the talks lunch fee but they
are not each other's closest relative in
the species tree this suggests a
possible horizontal transmission between
these taxa as well again hetero stropas
and DD males they made us ours are
distinct from the rest of the stalks one
tree suggesting the possibility of a
horizontal transmission but what we can
say for sure is that they're not similar
to the rest of the stalks the text in
the dataset so I have to breeze through
the GC and amino acid analyses but what
I'll point out is that in the GC
analysis the talks on proteins in
Cochabamba centers trophies and DD Mel's
and made us are significantly different
from the GC of the rest of the proteome
suggesting on a foreign acquisition or
at least a typical to the proteome amino
acid analysis concurs with our emphases
made from the topological analyses and
that there is evidence for vertical and
horizontal transmission what I'd like to
point out especially from the amino acid
analysis is the identity between the
genes and Coco Alba setters trophies and
these other attacks and note that
they're all relatively low in the 50
percentage --is
okay what this tells us is that if the
genes were horizon--
transmitted into co-collaborators
trochus it was likely not for many of
the taxa in our data sets we don't have
a strong link to a donor based on this
analysis so what have we learned about
media talks one evolutionary history do
the talks one cluster share a common
evolutionary origin from this
phylogenetic analysis we had identified
or we identified eleven species that
harbour the cluster and there is support
for a common evolutionary origin due to
the clustering and the individual gene
trees here I'm using peak s2 as an
example can we determine the mode of
inheritance of stalks one in Colaba
sitarist ofus from the phylogenetic
analysis what we can say is that stalks
one and colaba sort of stroke was raised
T is much different from other talks
when clusters found the other species we
can also say that talks one does not
conform to a pattern of vertical
inheritance and from the evaluation the
protein features we can say that talks
one is atypical relative to the rest of
the proteome in cocoa Viserys trophies
and low identity low amino acid identity
between the kilometers trophies genes
and the other taxa precludes any of
these taxa from being a possible donor
to KUKA Allosaurus trophies so to
summarize the first section of the talk
the talks one cluster appears atypical
within the genome based on GC analysis
this supports the hypothesis of
horizontal acquisition but without a
strong link to a donor species we cannot
exclude the possibility of vertical
inheritance and divergence of the
cluster the next part of my talk is
functional analyses what I was
interested in was this the role these
ABC gene and this oxido reductase gene
that are found in these other species
but not found in Cookeville etcetera
sofas the loss of these genes hypothesis
could have played a critical role in the
evolution of T toxin production so in
order to test that I deleted the genes
in one of these other species and
evaluated whether or not the species
produce tea stalks and after the genes
were deleted I also then attempted to
integrate these genes into Coco Albus
heterotroph is to see if once they're in
the genome if they disrupt or abolish T
toxin production so chosen for
functional analysis was quarried espera
cassia Cola which our collaborators have
shown to be genetically tractable and
from which the toxin one cluster has
been shown to play a role in virilis by
deletion of the PKS gene the approach I
use for genetic manipulation was
pioneered by Gillian and her colleagues
and involves the simple generation of
PCR fragments which contained a marker
selectable marker of interest flanked by
regions homologous to flanking regions
of a target gene to be deleted so
recombination of the PCR fragment with
the wild-type chromosome results in
replacement of the gene of interest with
the selectable marker I use this
approach to delete both the ABC and the
ox our genes in cornets broadcasting
Iacullo separately and then i assayed 40
toxin production I asked a 50 tox
reduction again using an approach that
was developed by Gillian and her
colleagues in which ecoli transformed to
express the e RF 13 protein the target
protein of T toxin are used because they
this this transformation can first
sensitivity to T toxin when plugs of
hyphy are placed onto a lawn of this e
coli a halo will be produced around them
if he talks in his presence so I played
in my mutants my ABC mutants and my
oxido reductase mutants onto lawns of E
coli expressed in you are 13 protein you
can see my controls are on the bottom
raised T which produces a halo brace o
which is not produced a toxin does not
produced a halo and the coordinates for
Cassie like a wild-type
you can see there's no strong halo in
any of my eye slits which tells me that
deletion of the IVC and Oxnard genes is
not results in T toxin production and
corn as for Cassie i below
so then I asked what about this into
what about integration and what about
moving these genes into the talks one
cluster well that somehow disrupts or
affect production of T toxin
I used a targeted gene insertion
approach also developed by Gillian
similar to the deletion approach except
in this case a gene of PCR fragments
carrying a gene of interest Frankie with
flanking regions homologous to a site of
interest are generated recombination of
this PCR fragments with the wild-type
chromosome results in insertion of the
gene of interest at the target site this
transformation is conducted with a
linearized plasmid conferring antibiotic
resistance so here's a basically my
approach here a PCR fragments carrying
individual core a spectacular genes
targeting them to the region neighboring
tox 9 and the in the tox one cluster and
I'm using taiga mice and be initially
Hydra mice and be and code
transformation so I did this as did this
experiment with the ABC gene
individually the ox r gene individually
and the ABC and the ox r gene together
and several attempts I found and
screening multiple candidates
I found one mutants that harbored both
the ABC and the oxido reductase gene
ectopic ly in the genome so not at the
target site of interest now this is
strange because this transformation
approach as so is been proven to be
extremely efficient and cook all the
ceteris trophies and other filamentous
phone phone John so what I would what I
considered was that it might be possible
that the target site that I was using
was somehow recalc insurance integration
something maybe that maybe because of
the 80 rich region along this flank that
I was having difficulty getting the gene
or I wanted it to be so what I did was I
conducted a separate experiment in which
I used those same flanking regions to
integrate my selectable marker directly
so I took high Hydra myosin gene for
Hydra mice and resistance and I put it
right into the same spot that I was
trying to put the other genes to see if
it would work
it worked it worked on the first try
we're just as efficiently as any other
transformation protocol that we used in
the lab my very first candidate I won
one had the gene correctly integrated so
I confirmed this by PCR evaluation and
also by crossing this mutant two array
so strain that does not produce T toxin
the rationale behind this is that if the
gene program is resistance is correctly
integrated at tox one then T toxin
production and Hydra myosin resistance
will Co segregate in the progeny of this
cross and that is what happened so here
on the left are high group is a Hydra
mice and B plates and here on the right
any plate with the coli assay but
equally expressing the or 13 protein
same clogs on both plates so what we see
race T ratio my controls and my high
integration mutant on the bottom on the
high plate no growth of race T and ratio
which is what we would expect growth of
my itemised integration and these are
individual ASCO spore progeny from the
cross of high going one to c5 you can
see that these three are growing on the
Hydra myosin plates and if you look over
on the coli assay plate those same three
are producing T toxin
this was true for 110 single aspect
spores that I evaluated so perfect Co
segregation between of T toxin
production and Hydra myosin resistance
indicating that the gene was correctly
integrated at talks one so having this
mutants with Hydra myosin resistance at
tox one gave us a platform from another
for another attempt with strong
selection to integrate the accordionist
forecast ocular genes in this case what
we're trying to do is use this use the
Hydra mice and be site is to replace
heiko mice and with our gene of interest
code transforming with a separate
selectable marker so the candidates from
this transformation will be resistant to
geneticist and then sensitive to Hydra
myosin meaning that the gene at the
locus was replaced
my gene of interest so I conducted this
experiment a few different times
screened a couple of hundred candidates
and found one mutants that had the gene
for the ABC transporter integrated again
topically somewhere else in the genome
so all of my candidates were then
genetics and resistant as well as Hydra
mice and resistant indicating that the
Hydra mice and gene was not being
replaced so one more attempt at this
integration is underway in which I'm
going to be using a a complementation
approach that was developed by Gillian
and in this case my gene to replace
[ __ ] myosin will be linked to like the
gene that I'm trying to integrate the
purpose behind this will be or the
rationale behind this is that the
resistance marker is linked directly
linked to the gene of interest so any
candidates that I have out of this
experiment that have genetics and
resistance should also have my target
gene right beside it so what I'm hoping
to happen is that I'll identify that
this will be reduced the number of false
positive candidates and that I'll be
able to recover isolate or mutants that
have the gene correctly integrated so
even if this is not successful
I still have generated a couple of
mutants one that has the ABC and the ox
are integrated it topically somewhere in
the genome and another that has the ABC
integrated separately also it topically
so I can use these in evaluation of test
my hypothesis firstly I check to see if
these mutants were expressing the ABC
and the oxidoreductase team by rt-pcr
cDNA and you can see here the ABC
fragment is present for both the ABC
mutants and the double mutants
indicating the ABC is expressed in those
mutants and the ox are one fragment is
present in the in the double mutant in
decay and that's expressed there so I
then conducting the ecole is a to see if
these mutants had any disruption or
abolishment of T toxin production and it
turns out not so integration that
topic integration and expression does
not disrupt DT toxin production in these
communities
so to summarize the functional analysis
part of my talk was the loss of the ABC
NOx r1 genes a critical turning point in
evolution of T toxin well deletion of
the ox r and ABC NOx our genes does not
result in production of T toxin and
Corinne s / cassia Aquila and insertion
of the genes it topically into include
all the Senators trophies does not
abolish T toxin production well although
I'm still working on him trying to get
these genes directly targeted it to the
talks when locus so just to summarize
the work I've done under these two
overarching questions what can we learn
about talks one evolutionary history
from these data and was the loss to the
ABC and ox our genes and critical
turning points my conclusions are that
tox one is much different in Colaba
serous trophies then the other talks
when clusters that we've identified
toxin one does not follow or conform to
a strict pattern of vertical inheritance
the GC analysis supports hypothesis a
foreign origin in Colaba status drove us
however the amino acid ID any analysis
precludes the possibility of any of the
tax in our data set being a potential
donor ensured the toxin cluster follows
a pattern of evolutionary of evolution
similar to other secondary metabolite
genes King discontinuity discontinuity
to cross several species fast evolving
and with evidence for vertical and
horizontal transmission among many
Angeles next was the loss of the ABC and
ox our genes a critical turning point in
evolution antitoxin productions you can
say that the deletion of them in cornets
bresca cycler doesn't result in t toxin
production and integration at a topic
size and expression does not disrupt or
abolish t toxin production and cook
allow the centrioles therefore the
presence or absence of these genes and
the tox one cluster is not alone
sufficient to result in
production of or the disruption of t
toxin therefore other factors must have
been involved in the evolution of t
toxin biosynthesis so at this time I'd
like to acknowledge a few people who've
been important to me in this past five
years primarily Gillian and the Turgeon
lab heejun Park who taught me literally
everything I know at the bench anyway
and Bradford Connor who laid most the
groundwork for the analyses that I did
and mijita Rico
Adriana who been friends and colleagues
throughout this past five years by
special committee Riya Harrison and
Magdalene collaborators ACOG II and
Kodama over in Japan as well as the
admin Phasis admin and facilities folks
here who keep they keep everything
moving for us in the department and I
think that they're really unsung heroes
especially especially Brian Flanagan if
you've ever had a chance to interact
with him he is like he's like 9 1 1 4
for us here fellow grad students and
faculty I couldn't list everybody but I
wanted to list a few people who were who
whether you knew it or not played a
really important role in my my success
here at the at this university and and
you've been friends to me and have been
supported above me and I just wanted to
give you a special shout out and
especially here Theresa velasca the
phylogenetic analysis I conducted I got
me started in the in that field I had no
experience in that at all Stuart Gray
who effectively was one of the people
that got me in here in the first place
Xiao Hong Kong I was on my was my field
representative in my a exam for some
reason let me let me get let me through
that and other people in and if an on
this list I it's I I just want you know
you know you know that you were there
and I appreciate your support
lastly I'm dedicating this whole
experience this past 10 years of college
actually to two people my mother
and my my dog who just passed away who
loved very much my mother doesn't look
like that anymore although if she kind
of still does in a real way and then he
was my hero and my best friend all right
thank you very much race key that was
the distribution that was the path of
the epidemic of the race of the southern
corn leaf blight epidemic uh yes I would
definitely assume that race Oh was known
since I think the 1920s to be a pretty
innocuous pathogen of corn it was not
considered a threat to agriculture but
it was it was known to exist in the
field so my question then is the gray
Steelers distributed that widely it only
ruined ten percent of the crop why
protection from race Oh from a ski and
many of the plants or did it what's it
just really poor and infecting large
numbers for you mean you mean race team
okay
Stewart's question is if race tea caught
me if I understand quickly the first he
was able to cause this massive epidemic
why is it only ten percent of plants
were affected ten percent of the crop
right
why was only ten percent well I would
have to look at the data regarding the
widespread use of tea cytoplasmic corn
so this interaction is so specific so
raised tea only accomplishes this hyper
virulent on t'east corn carrying the tea
cytoplasm so that ten percent I
don't know what the percentage of other
varieties of corn were being produced at
that time but I do know that 80% of corn
used for hybrid production carry the T
cytoplasm so what percentage of the corn
used what percentage of that was the
corn use altogether I'm not sure that's
a good question you're showing into the
season implications so in terms of the
rate at which is spread over the course
of the ceiling right throughout the
season if an LP had a question and I
like to answer that real quick this
Coast office yep that was that was the
plan what so what would the initial plan
was to get one of the genes in there and
then get the other gene in there and
with it but we had a really difficult
time getting accomplishing part a so so
Part B was was with never actually
accomplish what we what we would hope to
do is in the second approach using the
resistance marker linked to the popcorn
expertise language gene would be to get
that in there and then replace the
resistant marker with a different
resistant marker and the other genes so
then generating the double mutant so
that that would be the plan if I don't
think I'll make it before I graduate but
I'm definitely that's definitely a plan
yes makes me a question right so what I
can tell you is that raise T has lower
Fitness on n cytoplasm corn which is non
t cytoplasm corn so raise T is somehow
somehow it's quite a fitness cost to
produce this toxin
to the fungus whereas Raso it relative
to race Oh Morgan your attendings not
going to what's presumably co-regulated
regen like do you not have a lot of
motor what if it went in topically and
then also did you look at how much
expression you're even getting from that
integration yep yeah that's that's
excellent questions and those those all
that has been on table what Morgan's
asking is what about the promoter that
you're using when you're bringing corn
escort a cycle over what how much that
promoter is this is a promoter even
going to induce expression what about
the level of expression of the gene in
the mutants and this these are all
issues of concern that we are dealing
with I've actually just got this rt-pcr
data a couple weeks ago what I would
like to do of course is quantitative PCR
to see differential see if the the
extent of the expression of the genes
for in regards to the promoter question
what we did was in designing this
integration we went upstream from the
start sites I think five or six hundred
base pairs to attempt to ensure that we
had the promoter and so that extension
upstream actually and bordered went
right to the boundary of the the
neighboring gene so we think we got the
promoter in there another thing that we
considered doing was to swap out that
promoter within a different promoter
something that we know would work well
in Colaba sitters trophies but since we
know since we see that we're at least
getting expression we don't think that
that's that's necessary at this time yes
Adam the two genes
integration is the single integration
shown qcr that okay the transcripts are
being made did you do a new orangie
control for that experiment yep just DNA
that's there it might not be functional
transcript so the maintenance problems
like
or spontaneous mutations in the coatings
right absolutely so in in terms of part
Adams question or Adams comments were
that just because we're getting
transcript doesn't mean that we are not
detecting background DNA correct and
also just because we're getting
transferred doesn't mean we're getting a
translation so we don't know if the
proteins actually getting made in the
fungus that actually work that's also
things that have been concerning to us
and and how to address those things is a
something that we're considering and in
terms of whether or not we're getting
background DNA but I can tell you is
that my acting bans are correct for
their length based on the events on post
processes so there there's an intron
that's in those in between those bands
and because of the length of those bands
we don't we can it we can assume that
we're getting actual mRNA we don't have
any additional bands suggesting that
there is actual DNA being detected
yes that's really that's really
interesting question race t-there's I
think in the late 50s or 60s was the
first identification of race T and I
think that was in the Philippines if I'm
not mistaken after that I think there
was some state in the Midwest and
reported hyper virulence on corn but I
but I could have that history incorrect
so prior to the use of t cytoplasm corn
it would have been difficult to detect
race T in the field because there would
have been no specific host to result in
this hyper virulent trait it would have
been difficult to distinguish race T
from race oh so race so from the 50s
starting in the 50s as 1t cytoplasmic
corn was used and that was also when
race tea was first detected so prior to
that we really can't say okay John I was
just focusing a little bit on your your
species tree never looking at
but the spiri I think was the closest
relative difference so interpreting that
light of your hypothesis here does that
suggest then that Egypt both the
kabbalists have a rest robust and that
left this variant acquired through
horizontal transmission in two separate
events since sometimes since they
diverged from a common ancestor is that
is that kind of the inference that it
would have been two different times that
they acquired any heart separately that
that is that is definitely possible with
but we cannot we cannot make draw any
conclusions based on the clustering in
an artery or based on the amino acid
identity between the different gene
clusters so in that but it's definitely
possible that when we and we do assume
based on the evidence that we have that
there may have been multiple transfers
of the gene cluster but what i can say
is that lingo Maya sees in Goldie anis
is one of the most early diverging
Dissidia my seats and it carries the
genes and based on its clustering with
its nearest neighbor aquatic Asst in the
species tree and in the tox one tree it
looks like lingo my sees in gold anise
has been carrying the stalks one cluster
for a long time and that is and that is
one of the earlier diverging species in
the lineage so there we believed there
was some loss of the cluster and some
transfer of the cluster and this follows
a pattern of evolution that secondary
metabolites generally show Teresa branch
spread so just by eyeballing this gene
tree the branch lengths are much longer
to the know compared to species like
sure so Teresa
was that in our species tree we see very
short branch links especially within the
Delta do my sees and then there's this
one long branch as separates with a
video my sis from the arrocha my sees in
our talks one tree we see mass of the
vergence of all the sequences they're
spread out on these long branches
everywhere so these long branches
indicates that these these talks when
clusters are highly diverse from one
another which is what we would expect
given the nature of secondary
metabolites now that's not true in the
species tree because in the spacious
tree we're using highly conserved single
copy genes purpose of this because we
know that they are conserved and we
don't expect the branch lengths in that
tree to be very long we expect them to
be short those sequences are actually
very similar to one another and that's
why they're used in the analysis what
would be interesting would be to compare
the stalks one tree topology and those
branch links to other genes other
background genes in the and see if there
is a difference in the virgin's also
what I can tell you in support of this
answer is that tier wise there hangs
conducted a DND s analysis of the toxin
one genes and found that the stalks when
genes don't show any differential rate
of evolution compared to the background
genome I'm sorry and there is no
positive selection alright there are no
further questions thank you groaning
everybody today this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu